hallo, Mein Name ist Philipp martmann und ich bin der
europakandidat
für Die Grünen in Münster.
Landwirtschaft
und Naturschutz
sind 2 ganz Zentrale Anliegen für uns grüne.
wir wollen in der Landwirtschaft 1 System schaffen,
was uns Menschen
gesund ernähren kann und gesunde Lebensmittel
für alles schafft.
wir wollen aber auch eine Landwirtschaft schaffen,
die fair is für die Menschen die konsumieren,
aber auch für die Menschen, die in der Landwirtschaft
arbeiten und dort produzieren.
wir wollen eine Landwirtschaft haben,
die im Einklang
mit sozialstandards und mit der Natur is.
Naturschutz ist das 2. wichtige Thema an dieser Stelle.
wir wollen den Green Deal erweitern und ausbauen.
1 Green Deal, der die Natur schützt,
unsere lebensgrundlagen schützt und damit uns selbst.